doch auf diese situation möchte ich gern
ein auge werfen gemacht damit michael
lüders die realistische schätzen sie
denn ein dass es tatsächlich einen
vierer gipfel gibt auf regierungschef
ebene wo es um die ukraine krise geht im
augenblick spricht relativ wenig dafür
und selbst wenn es ihn geben sollte
würde sich an der grundsätzlichen
konstellation nichts ändern
die ukrainische regierung ist
entschlossen die probleme im osten des
landes militärisch zu lösen
und man darf vermuten dass sie diese
entscheidung nicht alleine getroffen hat
denn die ukrainische regierung ist im
wesentlichen zahlungsunfähig sie verfügt
nicht über die finanziellen mittel um
einen mittel- oder gar längerfristigen
krieg im osten des eigenen landes zu
führen gegen die russischen separatisten
oder diejenigen separatisten die
russland sehr nahe stehen die
möglichkeiten gibt es weder finanziell
noch militärisch wenn es dennoch dieser
weg beschritten wird dann muss es hier
sicherlich eine zusammenarbeit geben die
europäer sind wenig begeistert über
diese entwicklung denn es ist klar dass
je länger die krise andauert hier größer
auch die gefahr wird einer eskalation
es soll angeblich kontakte gegeben haben
zwischen der ukrainischen regierung und
der in washington
es sollen sich unter anderem auch 512
der blackwater organisation die sich
mittlerweile umbenannt hat aber bekannt
ist unter diesem namen bekannt geworden
ist durch die sollten die auch in den
irak geschickt worden sind etwa 500 also
an der zahl in der ukraine wir haben
also nicht nur russen die hier kämpfen
auf seiten der separatisten sondern auch
sollten auf seiten der regierung ist
eine gefährliche entwicklung eine ungute
entwicklung denn es ist ganz klar dass
eine eskalation nicht ausgeschlossen ist
und dieser konflikt kann außer kontrolle
geraten wenn die russische seite oder
wenn die ukrainische seite der meinung
ist sie könnte ganz auf sieg setzen
das heißt aber auch dass sie verstellen
dass es eine entfremdung gibt zwischen
europa zwischen den europäischen
politikern unter den usa den
amerikanischen politikern da wird längst
nicht mehr miteinander besprochen
ich habe den eindruck dass die europäer
allmählich zu greifen beginnen dass die
interessen der usa in der ukraine nicht
notwendigerweise die selben sind als die
der europäer insbesondere die
verschärfung der beziehungen
zu russland hat ja gravierende
wirtschaftliche folgen alleine der
wirtschaftliche austausch zwischen
deutschland und russland als ergebnis
der sanktion hat sich mehr als halbiert
im laufe des heurigen jahres das ist
eine summe in der größenordnung von 40
milliarden euro um die es geht wenn man
sich vor augen hält dass die amerikaner
traditionell nur relativ geringen handel
mit russland geführt haben in der
größenordnung von etwa 8 milliarden
dollar im jahr
dann ist völlig klar dass allen voran
deutschland aber auch andere europäische
staaten
die engen handeltreiben mit russland
massiv betroffen sind gerade die
wirtschaft ist darüber natürlich sehr
unglücklich und letztendlich bezahlen ja
die europäer einen großteil der
wirtschaftshilfe für die ukraine
diese wirtschaftshilfe ist aber wie es
scheint ein fass ohne boden es gibt ja
keine kontrolle was mit diesen geldern
passiert auf jeden fall fehlt es nicht
am geld und krieg zu führen
lernt ja die regierung in kiew für die
eigene bevölkerung im osten des landes
alle zahlungen eingestellt hat das ist
eine sehr gute konstellation
und eigentlich müsste eine vernunft
orientierte politik nicht nur klartext
reden an die adresse moskaus sondern
auch an die adresse die regierung in
kiew dass sie zurück findet an den
verhandlungstisch und nicht auf
militärische lösungen setzt die es im
falle der ost ukraine nicht geben kann
vergessen wir nicht dass die ukraine ein
land ist dass sowohl in richtung
russland wie auch in richtung europa
ausgerichtet ist und es ist ein
scharnier staat wenn man so will man
kann nicht die eine seite gewissermaßen
militärisch heraus operieren wollen bei
aller berechtigten kritik an der politik
russlands der europäischen diplomatie
denn mit guten worten einwirken in
richtung ukraine in richtung kiew das
hat insbesondere auch der deutsche
außenminister immer wieder versucht
versucht worden und durchgesetzt worden
sind die sanktionen das haben sie
angesprochen
wo gibt es denn da überhaupt noch ja den
spalte offen wo man den fuß dazwischen
setzen kann
ich glaube in letzter konsequenz geht es
um die frage ob die europäische union
und namentlich auch die bundesregierung
bereit ist gegenüber den amerikanischen
freunden klartext zu reden und zu sagen
diesen nicht gewillt einen krieg im
zentrum europas entstehen zu lassen der
weit entfernt erfolgt von den grenzen
amerikas aber doch in unserer
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft wir setzen
jetzt auf eine politik die versucht
einen mittelweg zu gehen
die bei aller kritik an russland gar
keine frage hier ist viel zu kritisieren
aber dennoch versucht die balance zu
finden und vor allem auch einer
entwicklung in der ukraine hingegen
wirkt die jedoch teilweise erstaunliche
tendenzen nimmt hier innere an den
auftritt von herrn jazenjuk der hier in
berlin kürzlich erklärte dass sowohl die
ukraine wie auch deutschland opfers
sowjetische aggressionen geworden sein
im zweiten weltkrieg das ist wie ich
meine eine gefährliche
geschichtsklitterung und ich hätte mir
sehr gewünscht dass die bundesregierung
hier klare worte an die adresse der
regierung in kiew gefunden hätte dass
man so nicht miteinander und
übereinander reden sollte man sollte die
geschichte nicht verfälschen sondern der
gegenwart mit augenmaß begegnen und ich
hoffe dass sich diese einsicht in berlin
und brüssel umsetzt dass man natürlich
mit kiew eng kooperieren sollte und muss
aber nicht um jeden preis noch eine
andere ziemlich neue meldung hätte das
auch nicht ganz kurz noch mal mit ihnen
schauen wollte wir hören heute dass
russland unter iran ein militärbündnis
abgeschlossen haben und da näher
zusammenrücken es eine überraschende
eine gefährliche tendenz und
zusammenarbeit
nein das ist eigentlich zu erwarten
gewesen nicht meine russland ist ja auch
nicht dumm
die regierung dort hat erkannt dass ihre
einseitige ausrichtung auf europa in
wirtschaftlicher hinsicht sich nicht
rechnet dass es einen bruch gibt der
sich fortschreiben wird über viele jahre
und russland ist dabei seine wirtschafts
und außenpolitik neu zu orientieren und
die großen nutznießer dieser entwicklung
sind china die türkei
der iran und indien in dieser
reihenfolge es entsteht ein neues
wirtschaftsbündnis wenn man so will
unter umgehung der europäer die
russische wirtschaft wird und den
sanktionen die nächsten drei bis fünf
jahre sicherlich massiv leiden aber die
wirtschaft ströme werden gerade völlig
neu sortiert und wir in europa werden
diejenigen sein die das nachsehen haben
denn diese staaten die sich hier
verbünden untereinander
wir sind ja durchaus wirtschaftsmächte
und der iran hat sehr viel öl zu
verkaufen und ist bereit eine
strategische allianz einzugehen mit
russland das ist natürlich auch einer
frau an die adresse des westens damit
verliert der westen ein druckmittel auf
die iranische regierung in sachen
wirtschaftssanktionen die nunmehr von
russland unterlaufen werden also hier
kann man beobachten wie auch in der
geopolitik neue konstellationen
entstehen
als ergebnis einer doch rechte
kurzsichtigen europäischen und
westlichen politik und am ende werden
vor allem wir steuerzahler in europa in
westeuropa namentlich in deutschland
diejenigen sein die die zeche zahlen das
ist eine sehr ungute entwicklung wir
sind nicht mehr die stärksten mächte auf
der welt im westen die welt sortiert
sich neu das müssen wir begreifen die
welt wird multipolare und rechthaberei
alleine ersetzt keine ergebnis
orientierte politik
bis dahin fehlen dank nach berlin hätte
das